The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
Monday's class really picks up
from the lecture we had this
past Monday.
We started crystal field theory
and then talked about
octahedral-shaped molecules and
splitting of d-orbitals.
And then on Monday,
we are going to continue with
that topic.
We are going to move in and
talk about tetrahedral
molecules, square planar
molecules and how they are going
to split the d-orbitals.
And then how that relates to
something, why we need to know
about any of that.
And that is because it is able
to predict some of the
properties of molecules,
like their colors and also
their properties in terms of
spin and using various different
spectroscopies to learn
something about particular
molecules, coordination
complexes.
Before we get into that unit,
we are going to kind of take a
step back and talk today about
shapes of molecules.
We introduced octahedral,
but now we are going to talk
about all the other kinds of
shapes of molecules in today's
lecture.
This is kind of jumping around
in the book a little bit.
We have been in Chapter 16.
And now, the way the book is
divided, this particular unit is
back in Chapter 3,
although it is referred to a
lot in Chapter 16.
This is kind of some of the
things that you need to know to
finish up Chapter 16.
And then on Monday we will be
back in Chapter 16 as well.
Again, this is a little bit odd
order because of the way the
calendar fell this year.
All right.
VSEPR, shapes of molecules,
why do we need to know about
this?
Well, as most of you know,
I do protein crystallography,
which is all about structure.
So, of course,
I am going to think that
structure is important,
that shape and geometry are
important.
And, in fact,
they have an influence on the
physical properties and chemical
properties of molecules.
Things like melting points,
boiling points,
reactivities,
and, in particular,
in biological systems it is
important.
A biological system has
particular shapes of chiral
molecules, it is a chiral
environment, which we have
talked about before.
And so molecules must fit
precisely in that environment.
Often, if you are talking about
an inhibitor of an enzyme,
the inhibitor or the
pharmaceutical drug is designed
so it specifically fits into a
particular crevice in an active
site and blocks activity.
A lot of the world of
pharmaceuticals is all about
shape of molecules and how you
design particular types of
shapes of molecules.
We have learned a lot about
this sort of area already,
and we found that the shapes of
molecules can be predicted
pretty well using simple methods
based on Lewis structures and
also in terms of thinking about
sort of where orbitals are and
how that may affect the
particular shape of the
molecules.
Again, this is sort of a
simplistic view that works
pretty well.
And it will be also,
on the next problem set,
a good opportunity for you to
review Lewis structures before
you take the final.
Sometimes this unit is with
Lewis structures,
there is some rationale for
that, but it is also kind of
nice to come back to it later in
the semester as a way to review
things that you learned before
and get you ready for the final
exam.
The particular theory we are
going to talk about today is
referred to as VSEPR.
And this is the valence-shell
electron-pair repulsion theory.
And so, like crystal field
theory, you are talking about
repulsive effects.
Here this is based on a simple
principle that valence electron
pairs will repel each other and
that the geometry around a
central atom will be such to
minimize that repulsion.
This is a lot like crystal
field theory,
where we were talking about the
splitting of the d-orbitals.
And we are talking about
ligands as negative point
charges heading toward those
d-orbitals.
A lot of these theories that
work pretty well are just really
based on the idea that repulsion
is unfavorable.
It is a pretty simple concept
which can explain a lot in terms
of properties of molecules.
Before we get into this,
there is always nomenclature
that we must deal with.
And here is the nomenclature
here.
We have A as a central atom.
Whatever is in the middle,
which when we are talking about
transition metals,
complexes would be your metal,
but this works for organic
chemistry as well,
when you are all talking about
carbon, oxygen,
sulfur, nitrogen.
And X is going to be your bound
atom, and E will be a lone pair
of electrons,
hence the E.
There are just a few rules.
It is not too bad compared to
some of the other things we have
done.
Just a handful of rules that
you need to know.
First, you need to know that
the steric number,
abbreviated S.N.,
is used to predict geometries,
and what steric number refers
to.
It refers to the number of
atoms bound to central atom,
plus the number of lone pair
electrons on the central atom.
Here we are not concerned about
double or triple bonds.
We are only concerned about how
many things are around our
central atom,
both the bonded and the lone
pairs.
Whether it is a double or a
triple bond doesn't matter at
all for these cases.
It is the number of atoms
bonded, not the number of bonds,
which is important to remember.
And so steric number,
here, should not be confused
with coordination number,
which we talked about in
transition metals,
--
-- which is just the number of
ligands around the central
metal.
So, there are a number of
different things that you are
going to learn about.
All right.
For resonance structures,
you can imply a VSEPR to any
one of them.
And there are two cases that we
need to consider today.
One is the case when there are
no lone pairs,
and other is the case when
there are lone pairs.
Those are all the rules.
It is really not too
complicated for this.
We are just going to go through
today and look at all these
different molecules and consider
the nomenclature and the
geometry around them.
First, we will consider formula
type.
And so AX two would
mean that you have a central
atom A, and we have two atoms
bound to it, so two Xs.
And now we are considering the
cases without lone pairs of
electrons, so there won't be any
Es until later.
Then the steric number is going
to be two.
And so here would be the shape
of the molecule.
And so we have a center atom
and two atoms bound to it.
It would have linear geometry
and a bond angle of 180.
That is pretty simple.
Now, we go to the next
category, where you have three
things bound,
so that would have an SN number
of three.
And this is going to be the
shape of that molecule.
And what is this called?
Trigonal planar.
And what are the angles?
120.
Okay.
Now, if we move up to four,
and this one should be pretty
familiar to you,
if we have four things bound,
SN number of four,
this is the molecular shape
that we have.
And you all know this as
tetrahedral.
And the angles of tetrahedral
are 109.5.
These are all things you have
to memorize.
This is written in your notes,
but if you don't look at your
notes and just try to think
about it, it will be a good
review for the next exam on this
topic.
All right.
If we go into the next
category, when we have five
things bound,
that would be AX five,
five atoms bound,
SN number of five.
We have this trigonal
bipyramidal geometry.
And what are the angles around
the equator here connecting the
red atoms?
120.
And what about red to black?
90.
All right.
Then, if we go to the next
category, when we have six
things, we talked a lot about
this in the last two classes,
what kind of geometry is this?
It is octahedral geometry,
with angles of 90.
Right.
These are all the basic shapes
when you just have two through
six atoms bound.
Let's take a look at a couple
of examples of molecules when we
have actual atoms listed.
If we look at CO two,
what is our SN number?
Two, right.
We are only considering the
number of atoms bound.
We don't care that they are
double bonds.
We are only concerned with the
atoms that are linked to the
central atom here.
Then the geometry is what?
Linear.
And angles?
180, right.
We will look at another example
here.
Is this one going to be the
same or different from the one
above?
The same, right,
because we don't care about the
double or triple bonds.
We can go through.
SN number is still two.
It is still linear.
And the angle is still 180.
We move into another example
here.
And I will just say that these
lecture handouts have this
information in here.
This is the most requested
lecture handout that I have from
people who have been in the
classes who get up to other
level classes and need to know
this stuff.
And, for some reason,
some of them have not kept
their 5.111 notes sort of next
to their pillow in later years.
I am not really sure why,
but sometimes it gets lost and
they request this handout,
because it is a really nice
summary of all of these things.
You might want to keep it in a
nice special place for future
reference.
All right.
Some day I should bring in what
my freshman chemistry textbook
looked like with like everything
highlighted and stuff just for
entertainment value.
All right.
This molecule here would have a
SN number of three.
And its shape again?
Trigonal planar.
And angles?
180.
By the time you get through
with lecture today,
you should have all of this
memorized, because we are going
to see these a couple more
times.
All right.
This one, what molecule is
this?
Does someone know its name?
Methane, right.
Again, what is this geometry?
Tetrahedral.
SN number of four.
And angles of?
109.5, right.
Okay.
Now we get into a few more
complicated molecules that you
do not see quite as often,
although I think we have seen
this one quite often in
different kinds of problems,
including chemical equilibrium
and other things.
SN number here?
Five.
Geometry?
It is hard to say that one in
unison.
We can work on this for the end
of lecture.
Then we can all say it in
harmony.
All right.
And our angles again?
Yeah.
Okay.
And one last one.
This should be very familiar to
you.
This is SN number six.
Geometry?
Octahedral.
Angles?
90.
Okay.
People are doing well.
Here is some stuff that you may
not have heard before,
or maybe have in another
chemistry course,
but now we are going to
introduce lone pairs and see
what effect this has.
It gets a little bit more
complicated at this point.
For lone pairs,
we think of them as being sort
of centrally located.
And I brought in some props to
talk about the spatial
distribution of electrons.
One can imagine that the
electrons are spread out as far
as they can go.
They like to have a lot of
space.
And so the lone pair electrons
are going to take up more space
and experience more repulsion
then when you have the electrons
as part of bonds to atoms.
The lone pairs are not sort of
held in as much,
they are not sort of forced to
be in one location,
so they will spread out more.
And so because of this,
their spreading out more,
they are taking up room,
they are kind of pushing
everything away,
because they want to have as
much room as they possibly can.
That means that lone pairs are
going to be more repulsive than
the atoms that are bound.
Even though electrons are
involved in those bonds,
they are not quite as bad.
The worst thing you can have is
two sets of lone pairs near each
other.
They want all the room.
And so they are going to be
sort of bumping into each other
and trying to force the other
set farther away.
See, this is much more bulky
than if you just have the two
atoms bound with bonds to a
central atom.
The next would be a lone pair
versus a bonding pair.
And then the least repulsive
will be two bonding pairs
because those electrons are sort
of fixed into locations for the
bonds.
They are not requiring as much
space.
They are not sort of spreading
out and taking over all the
space that is available.
Worst is lone pair-lone pair,
then lone pair bonding,
and then bonding-bonding.
And, if you think about this
sort of simple rule,
you can predict a lot about the
shapes of molecules.
Let's look at what shape
something will have if it has
this sort of set molecule.
Again, A, the central atom.
X is four atoms that are bonded
to the central atom,
and E is one set of lone pair.
And so this is going to have
what is known as a seesaw shape.
And let's think about why that
would be the case.
If we have this sort of central
framework, but one of these
bonded atoms is now going to be
replaced with a lone pair.
There are five things around
this framework.
One is a lone pair.
Where are you going to put it?
If we put it on top,
what are the angles between
these lone pairs on top and the
three red bonded atoms?
90.
That is kind of close and not
so favorable.
If we instead put one over
here, then we have still the
sort of negative interaction
with the 90 here and the 90
here.
But we only have two of them
instead of three.
And these guys are 120 apart,
so it is not so bad.
There is a little bit more
space in the equatorial
position.
And so that is why you get this
seesaw shape,
because you would want to put
it in the equatorial position,
where there is only sort of
these two rather than three.
There is just a little bit more
space, because these guys are
farther away.
That gives rise to seesaw
geometry.
You can sort of again,
these rules are more to explain
in retrospect what is observed
about those molecules,
and then you rationalize.
But the rationalization works
pretty well.
If we do that,
if we put a lone pair,
then, here, instead of one of
these top positions,
we get this seesaw geometry.
And so let me help you remember
this.
See?
Get the seesaw geometry.
How many of you actually grew
up with seesaws in the
neighborhood playground?
Still most people,
okay.
They are actually one of the
most dangerous toys.
And I think a lot of
playgrounds have removed them
because of the one kid who sort
of sits on it and keeps you,
like, stuck up in the air
because they are a little
heavier than you are.
And you are stuck there for a
really long time,
and then eventually they get up
and you go falling and flying.
We may have to give this a new
name at some point when all
seesaws are removed from
playgrounds, but it sounds like
it is still usable.
Now, if we wanted to put
another lone pair on that same
structure, we still have
essential atom,
three atoms bound.
Now we have two lone pairs.
Those two lone pairs,
then, will go into the
equatorial positions as well.
And so you kind of have this
sort of arrangement.
And they were so repulsive they
actually made the atom unbonded
from it.
Okay.
That leaves you with this
shape, which is a T-shape
molecule.
Again, this is a
rationalization.
Someone figured out that a
molecule like this had this
T-shape ad it could be
rationalized by the fact that
the lone pairs wanted to sort of
fill out in that equatorial
plane.
And they could move away
slightly from each other,
and that would minimize the
amounts of repulsion.
All right.
If we keep going here and look,
now, at a molecule with this
geometry, AX four E two
molecule.
That is based on kind of what
structural framework?
What is the sort of parent
structure when you have six
things bound?
Yeah, based on an octahedral
geometry.
If you take your octahedral
molecule and if you want to
figure out where you are going
to put your lone pairs,
you could stick one down here
in the equatorial,
but that doesn't do you as much
good this time because now your
other equatorial things are at
90.
This one would have a lot of
crashes down here.
What ends up happening is the
two lone pairs would go one
above and one below,
so they would be as far away
from each other as possible.
You have one below and another
one on top.
And remember,
the worst thing to have is a
lone pair-lone pair.
Even though you have four atoms
at 90 that it is interacting
with, at least it is far away
from the other lone pair.
Each kind of gets half the
molecule, one up top and one on
the bottom, so they have the
most room, those electrons,
to spread out.
And so that gives you what kind
of geometry?
Square planar,
right.
All right.
You can also predict something
about what might happen to the
angles that you have all now
pretty much memorized on the
previous slides.
That if you do have a lone
pair, and out here we have an AX
three E,
SN number of four,
so four things bound,
one lone pair and three atoms,
and this is based then on what
kind of structure?
With SN number of four,
what is the kind of the parent
geometry there?
Yeah, tetrahedral is the parent
geometry.
And now we have replaced one of
the bonded atoms with a lone
pair.
And so what that is going to do
is that lone pair is really not
in that bad of shape.
You put it on top.
You have 109.5 now between
those angles pointing down in
the parent geometry.
And that was better than the
others which were at 90,
but it is still not good enough
for it.
And so it actually presses down
even more.
Those lone pairs,
they are going to spread out as
much as they possibly can and
repel those bonded atoms away to
the extent possible.
In this molecule,
what is observed is that the
angles in between here,
in between the hydrogens,
instead of being 109.5,
which is what you would expect
for the true tetrahedral
geometry, they are 106.7.
This lone pair is pressing
down, compressing the bonded
atoms even closer to each other
than what is sort of the normal
framework.
This really takes up a lot of
room here and is repulsive
toward these bonded angles.
Again, the VSEPR theory can
predict these kinds of,
or really explain these kinds
of changes.
If you observe the smaller
angle you can say,
oh, there was a lone pair.
That makes sense that it would
be a smaller angle because there
would be repulsion down.
Again, you can think about it.
You can make one of these lone
pairs yourself,
low tech and think about the
shapes here.
All right.
We can also rationalize the
difference between a PH3 and NH3
molecule.
They have pretty much the same
framework here,
based on tetrahedral geometry
AX3E, SN number of four.
But now, instead of the number
for methane that we saw of
109.5, and instead of the 106.7
for NH3, we now get a really
small angle between here,
between the angle between
hydrogen and phosphorus.
And hydrogen is now 93.3,
so it is even more compressed.
And the reason why is because
we are moving down in the
Periodic Table.
And so as we move down the
column in the Periodic Table,
we are going to have lone pairs
that have even larger spatial
volumes.
And so they are going to
compress even more.
Now it is an even bigger sort
of situation here.
The lone pairs are trying to
fill up even more volume.
And so they are sort of trying
to compress as much as possible
these atoms away.
They are filling up all
available space and making the
angle here even smaller.
And so if asked about this,
if asked to predict,
you could sort of look at where
things are in the Periodic
Table.
Here is nitrogen,
here is phosphorus.
And so if we had a compound
based on nitrogen or phosphorus
that was based on tetrahedral
geometry, one might expect that
the angle becomes even smaller
as you move down the Periodic
Table, as that lone pair that is
on there is filling up even more
and more spatial volume.
This kind of combines ideas of
trends in the Periodic Table
with shapes of molecules.
All right.
Another thing that you can
sometimes predict is about bond
lengths.
If you experimentally observed
different bond lengths in a
molecule, you could use VSEPR to
go back and think about where
that may have come from.
What is this geometry here,
the one that is shown and also
the parent geometry?
The one that is shown is what?
Seesaw.
And the parent geometry?
Right, trigonal bipyramidal.
All right.
Here we have AX four E.
We have an SN number of five.
We have four atoms bound.
We have one lone pair.
And now it is observed that
there are two sets of SF bonds.
One set is 1.545,
and one is 1.646.
What do you think those
different bond sets --
There are two types of bonds.
We have one lone pair.
Likely one set would involve
the gray atoms,
and the other would be the
black atoms.
Which do you think would be
longer?
Do you think the gray or the
black would be longer,
the bond lengths from the
central atom to the gray or to
the black would be longer?
Gray.
And why is that?
Right, because these are at 90
going down.
Whereas, this is at 120.
The 90 is more repulsive,
so it basically kind of pushes
that up farther and down
farther, moves them farther
away.
The black atoms are already
farther and won't feel the
repulsion as much.
Another way to sort of,
if you have a lone pair here,
for the lone pair to feel like
it really has the space that it
requires, is to sort of repel
the atoms that are closer in
terms of distance,
repel them just a little bit
farther away.
And then it can kind of fill
out and feel like it has enough
space.
Again, if you had an
experimentally observed set of
bond lengths,
you could rationalize using
VSEPR, why you would have this.
Okay.
As we said, more repulsion
between the lone pair electrons
and the axial ones because those
are at 90, so those would move
farther away.
That is a lot of the theory.
Now we are just going to run
through these sheets and talk
about the different types of
geometries, the names of the
different types of geometries
when you have the lone pairs on
there.
And then look at some examples.
Again, if you call out the
answers, and if we go through
this quickly,
this is all that we need to go
over for today,
and it will be a good review.
You will sort of have the
opportunity, today,
to memorize this.
You might want to go back over
it a couple times,
but pretty much this is the
whole unit.
It is not too challenging.
If we have AX two E,
we are going to have a SN
number of three.
And a molecular shape.
I will draw that.
And what is the name of that
geometry?
It is bent.
And that is because you are
only considering the bonded
atoms.
You are not talking about the
lone pair.
We don't really see the lone
pair, two bends,
and so it would just look bent
to us.
That is where that comes from.
And what angles would this have
for this particular case,
SN number of three?
Okay.
We have this one here.
The SN three would have a
trigonal planar parent geometry.
But if we take a lone pair and
put that on instead of an atom,
then it will also be somewhat
compressing of those two atoms
down there.
We won't really know,
without knowing what the
central atom is,
we cannot really predict how
bad the compression is going to
be.
What you would put is less than
120 here, because it would be
120 if this was an atom and not
a lone pair.
If this is a lone pair,
then it is less than 120.
All right.
Here is another case.
Now we have three atoms bound,
one lone pair,
SN number of four.
And our parent geometry here
would be tetrahedral.
And now we have a lone pair.
We saw this a little bit
before.
And what is that geometry
called?
Here, we have this picture.
What is this called?
Trigonal pyramidal.
We have this.
And what would the angles be
here?
Less than 109.5.
All of you should know the
answers because they are
actually in your handout,
so feel free and confident to
yell them out.
All right.
Again, this is going to be less
than 109.5 because we have a
lone pair pressing down.
You have to in all these cases
consider what the parent
geometry is.
And then the angles are going
to be a little less than that if
you have one lone pair sitting
on top.
All right.
AX two E two has a SN
number of four.
All right.
What geometry is this based on?
Yeah, tetrahedral again.
We have two lone pairs on that.
And what does that look like it
should be called?
Bent as well.
And now the angles are going to
be less than 109.5.
So, you see,
we have two bent molecules,
but the angle isn't the same.
It depends on whether it is
based on a trigonal planar or it
is based on tetrahedral.
You need to sort of know what
the whole molecule was to figure
out what degree of bend you have
in these two.
All right.
AX four E has SN
number of five.
And so our shape here,
what is this one going to be?
Yeah, this is going to be a
seesaw.
And so what are our angles
going to be?
Right, less than 120,
less than 90.
It could be that really the 120
are not going to be that
affected, but that will be what
you will put down because you
don't really know.
This is just a rough predictor
of what those are going to be,
so it is less than what the
parent molecule was.
All right.
SN number of five.
And so what are we going to be
doing here?
We are going to add another
lone, take off an atom,
add another lone pair.
And what are we going to get
here?
Right, T-shaped.
And the angles will be...
At this point is our T-shape,
and so we will have less than
90.
You will have the two lone
pairs in the equatorial
position, as we talked about
before, trying to spread out as
much as they possibly can.
Now we are replacing another
one with a lone pair.
Another bonded atom.
Our SN number is still five.
And what shape are we going to
get in that case?
Linear, right.
They all go in these equatorial
positions to spread out as much
as they possibly can.
And so we are going to end up
with a linear molecule,
so we would replace here.
And what are our angles here?
They are exactly 180.
Yeah?
It could be that there would,
but they probably will just be
really spreading out around to
fill out as much room as
possible around the whole
equatorial place.
You can just sort of think
about it as if there was space,
they would move into it,
so they have really filled up
this space.
And pretty much you might as
well keep them there,
because whichever way they
move, they are just going to get
repelled in another direction.
That's kind of the one
exception, are these ones that
turn out to be linear.
There is one other exception
where the angles are not going
to change as well,
where you have orbitals on kind
of either side that counteract.
That is a good question.
All right.
One more.
We have AX five E,
SN number of six.
This is based on what parent
molecule?
Octahedral.
We are going to take off one
ligand, and so this would be,
if we removed one of the
ligands here,
we get this parent shape,
which is called square
pyramidal.
And what are the angles going
to be, here?
Less than 90.
Okay.
Every year, when I do this
unit, I like to reward people
who are in class.
And so I give a little hint
about the final.
And the hint will be that this
will be on the final,
[LAUGHTER] so you might want to
put that down.
The last couple of years I did
seesaw, which really is my
personal favorite,
but at some point I have to
switch.
This time it will be this one.
And it is always so sad to me
when people get that one wrong,
so please get that one right.
Okay.
Let's keep going.
SN number is six.
And so we are going to put on
another lone pair.
And where are we going to put
it?
We are going to try to move it
so that there is the least
amount of repulsion between the
lone pairs, so it is going to be
up on top.
This geometry keeps the lone
pairs as far away from each
other as possible.
And what is the remaining thing
called when you have those lone
pairs on there?
That is going to be square
planar.
And what about the angles in
this case?
In this case they are just 90,
because you have a lone pair on
top pushing down and a lone pair
on the bottom pushing up.
This is another example where
it is not less than.
All right.
Next one.
We add another lone pair.
And at this point does it
matter where you put the lone
pair?
No.
They are all equivalent
positions, so it doesn't make
any difference.
It is going to be one of these
guys gets replaced,
and so that is going to leave
you with the what geometry?
T-shaped.
And angle here is going to be
this time less than 90,
right, because it will repel
this one and this one if you
have a big lone pair in this
position.
All right.
One more.
Again, the same geometry.
We take another bonded atom off
and put another lone pair.
And what are we left with in
this case?
Linear.
Again, this is going to be 180.
All right.
Now we have looked at all of
those, and we can very quickly
go down.
And in this handout,
I have most of it written.
I don't have the angles,
so that you can write the
angles in and have your complete
set for this as well.
Now let's look at water.
The Lewis structure for water,
you would end up with two lone
pairs on the oxygen.
And so what formula type would
this be?
AX two E two.
SN number of four.
Geometry?
Bent angle.
Less than 109.5,
because this is based on the
tetrahedral geometry.
Remember, bent could either be
less than 120 or less than
109.5, but if you have a SN
number of four then it is based
on tetrahedral geometry.
It would be less than 109.5,
which is the tetrahedral
angles.
Okay.
SF four,
here is our structure.
Formula type for this would be?
AX four E.
And that is a SN number of
five.
And the shape?
Seesaw.
And angles?
Yeah, less than 90 and less
than 120.
Here is another one,
BrF three.
These are all probably ones
that you did Lewis structure
for.
If not, I am sure you will
before the final.
Here is another one.
The formula type for this would
be AX three E two.
And SN number?
Five.
And geometry?
T-shaped.
Angles?
Less than 90.
Okay.
If we keep going,
here is another example,
selenium and fluoride.
And we have three sets of lone
pairs.
What is the formula type?
AX two E three.
SN number of five.
Geometry?
Linear.
Angle?
180.
Okay.
BrF five. Formula type?
AX five E. SN number?
Six. Geometry?
Square pyramidal.
Angles?
Less than 90.
You want to remember that one.
Okay.
Here is another one with an
addition lone pair.
Formula type?
AX four E two.
SN number?
Six. Geometry?
Square planar.
Angle?
90, exactly.
That completes that list.
Again, the theory of VSEPR,
you are taking experimental
results and then trying to apply
a theory to it.
It is not good at really making
exact predictions about things.
But it is really good at
rationalizing what they have.
All right.
Have a wonderful Thanksgiving,
everybody.